[Applause]
[Music]
so yeah it is not surprising but it is
finally official the fact that Ben
Affleck is leaving the role of Batman
after having played it for two times in
a cameo in the DC superhero film
universe that they don't want us to call
the DCU but we all do so yeah like I
said this is not surprising it's been a
rumor for a while and he he hasn't
seemed like he's wanted to be there like
especially out on the press junket but
his performance in Justice League
he didn't seemed especially engaged and
you know he he's obviously he's got a
lot going on in his person I'm like I
don't follow a ton of the personal life
of celebrities cuz I don't care but like
I know that he did a voluntary stint in
rehab the guy's been going through some
stuff and I'd uh I don't think too many
people are gonna blame him for walking
away at this point so you know I don't
want to dwell too much on the actual
decision for him to leave and I said I
do suspect that it was his decision
because you know he's still he's he's a
talented guy and and I do think that the
that Warner Brothers is still trying to
figure
still trying to figure out what they're
gonna do and if they ever pull off you
know the the flashpoint movie you know
to actually reset or or otherwise sort
of manually adjust this universe and
who's in it and how it works they would
have liked to have had him on hand to at
least sign off the role but that's not
gonna happen now so what does this mean
and how does this sort of fit into the
bigger picture of other recent Warner
Brothers news because there's actually
been a few things that have come out
lately
in regards to the DC properties well the
first is is that in addition to
confirming that Ben Affleck would not be
playing the role anymore the Matt Reeves
directed the Batman is apparently now
slotted in for 2021 now this is the
first time we've gotten a date on this
Matt Reeves has been working on this for
I guess about a year now if I'm
remembering my dates correctly so this
this is the first time they've actually
said here's when it's coming out now he
also spoke recently about the project
and sort of his angle on it and he seems
to want to put a lot of emphasis on the
detective element of Batman he talked
about having a new our style focus which
is not a bad idea because Batman as
ninja as badass vigilante you know
that's kind of been done to death at
this point the Batman detective angle
has really not gotten a lot of play in
the movies Batman as a detective has
shown as basically had its best showing
outside of the comics in TV shows Batman
the Animated Series he you know came
across as a detective heck Adam West of
Batman felt like a detective the movie
Batman
not really it's never really been the
case they've tried like little nods here
and there but ultimately you know he's
just he's just there to beat somebody up
more often than not and sometimes that
works fine but it is a pretty good way
to go at it from a new angle and given
what Ben Affleck's Batman had been up to
this point it's probably going to go
smoother with a new take on a new actor
playing Bruce Wayne who isn't gonna have
the baggage of you know beating the crap
out of Superman in power armor you know
the while while you can go on all you
want about the Batman V Superman themes
being dark and edgy that was not a noir
film I'm not entirely sure what it was
but it
the going for noir going for genuine
noir is gonna be something a little bit
different it'll be dark which Batman is
at its best usually and you know it but
it'll be a slightly different
way to come at it which i think is a
good thing I think that'll be a cleaner
transition without Ben Affleck I mean
that I just feel that's the reality of
it as far as some other stuff that's
been announced
it looks some hike I really do worry
about Warner Brothers because they seem
to be getting better like Wonder Woman
was pretty good
Aquaman was decent wasn't awful and
actually I didn't even hate Justice
League that much they seem to be
correcting pretty well but I do still
worry because we got our first glimpses
of like footage from birds of prey and
it was like literal fractions of a
second shots of like a half-dozen
characters and a heck of a lot of
lingering on Harley Quinn now Margot
Robbie as Harley Quinn was the highlight
of Suicide Squad one of only a few
things that really kind of worked about
that film but I've seen this Harley
Quinn I want to see the other characters
who are in this and the rumor now is I
don't believe this is government at this
point that Warner Brothers wants Byrd is
afraid of a launching point for a
trilogy which immediately makes me
nervous because wanting because getting
preoccupied with all the films they'll
get to make after the one they're
currently making is such a huge part of
why things went just imploded previously
so that rumor unconfirmed at this point
does make me nervous and it does and
like the the little bits of you know
marketing that we got and sort of the
the way that it's coming out things that
makes me nervous the other thing that
like makes me kind of go like oh but
then I get a little bit more the details
I'm like oh so now there is word that
Warner Brothers is considering doing a
Batman Beyond film cool animated cool
and the only reason they're considering
doing this is basically in response to
Sony's into the spider-verse
that doesn't render the project
meaningless or without merit or mean
that it won't be good but the the fact
that Warner Brothers just seems to be
scrambling about running around like a
chicken with its head cut off trying to
latch on to anything that might work
this just adds to that feeling and it's
the feeling that I was starting to see
them shake off and now I really do worry
that they're just gonna they're gonna
dive back into it it's you know it's a
case of they were moving forward with
these films and you know Batman V
Superman didn't was not what they wanted
it to be Justice League really wasn't
what they wanted it to be so they kind
of go okay slow down let's take it easy
let's try and you know get some things
sorted out let's get better and then
Aquaman comes out and again pretty
decent movie and becomes their biggest
hit so far and I worry that they then
kind of like sand go oh we've got a hit
now great let's get back with all the
plans that we were doing that we put on
hold no you had to keep putting those on
hold because they need more foundation
than just Aquaman and Wonder Woman so
like I I cannot help but be nervous
basically by anything that is handled by
Warner Brothers their entire approach to
IP management just really frustrates me
and this impacts Harry Potter as well
which I'm planning on doing another
video and in a week or two talking about
why I think that franchise at least in
film is pretty much screwed so I
remember what was it three four years
ago where Warner Brothers basically
announced that they were going to stop
making mid-tier budget movies and they
were only going to they know not
distribute but like actually actively
produce on the lot devote their direct
time and money and efforts into
DC movies Harry Potter movies and Lego
movies and yeah I know why because those
kinds of franchises where the big
money's been lately but that's they put
a lot of eggs and only a few baskets and
I think two of those well one of those
baskets might be recovering the other
one I'm not sure can but now I'm
starting to get into stuff that'll
probably touch on when I talk about the
Harry Potter stuff so yeah the this is
kind of a mixed news cycle in regards to
the DC movies Ben Affleck out in my mind
kind of neutral I would have to have
liked to see him play Batman in a better
movie I'm not gonna get to that's a bit
of a bummer but like I said I think if
Matt Reeves is taking the whole thing in
a new direction probably better to get a
new Batman Batman beyond cool in the
interest of chasing a trend it makes me
nervous you know birds of prey is coming
out cool first teaser is all Harley
Quinn and they're talking about it being
first in a trilogy that approach makes
me nervous you know this I don't trust
Warner Brothers I just don't and you
know there's a reason that I cite Warner
Brothers when I talk about these DC
movies but I rarely cite Disney when I
talk about the Marvel movies which is
that the Disney level executives rarely
get directly involved in the Marvel
movie making machine that's they leave
that division alone to do its own thing
whereas Warner Brothers they're top
level executives are notorious for
getting very involved and micromanage II
on all the projects they don't let these
directors and these producers just make
it they always have notes so that's why
I can't talk about the DC stuff without
talking about Warner Brothers as a whole
whereas with Marvel I can talk about
Marvel without necessarily having to
talk about Disney it's just
that they don't know when to just let
the good thing be the good thing it's
like oh it's the good thing great how
can we Memphis that's just what they are
now so yeah
mixed Batman DC movie news what do you
think about any of this stuff I just ran
bulld about whatever your thoughts are
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about a whole bunch of stuff
that you can do because there's buttons
there's links there's a link to my
patreon I recently restructured the
rewards it's now easier to get your name
and the ending credits which will be
coming up in a little bit maybe check
that out if you feel like it um there's
other links to look at if you don't want
to look at that but you know what if you
don't want to look at any of it that is
okay because at the end of the day folks
you're the council I just run these
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]